closing coal-fired power stations was
good for cutting Scotland's greenhouse
gas as the chimneys fell
this was tech NZ four years ago so did
the emissions steeply but then not so
much the Committee on climate change has
looked at 2017 the first year after coal
its warned that Scotland risks missing
its target it's not meeting its targets
in the future so far it's doing okay but
the challenge that lies ahead to get to
Net Zero by 2045 is an immense one it's
a challenge that the Scottish government
can meet but it involves making steps
that previously we haven't made in
particular and addressing emissions from
transport Scotland set a world-leading
target of achieving Net Zero gas
emissions by 2045 five years before the
rest of the UK the climate change
Committee says Scotland needs what it
calls a step change in ambition to meet
its steeper reduction targets as well as
transport it says problem areas to be
addressed include housing buildings all
the new should be energy efficient in
agriculture it says well carbon methods
should be employed more trees should be
planted and carbon storing peatlands
restored as well as the urgency of
climate change policy there is the
pressing issue here of credibility next
year world leaders will gather in
Glasgow for a global summit on climate
change the Scottish government says it
welcomes the new report calling it a
massive boost to Scotland's climate
change credentials saying it agrees with
the challenges set how they're addressed
will be the measure of success
Jim's Mathews Sky News Glasgow